this is the false gods him a soundtrack
for the amigdala that's left over in the
Falls of Blood Bones Network test and
this him eventually became the track
known as hail the nightmare which is
played as you explore yaha cool an area
that's littered with amygdala I'm
playing that song for you in the
background here but I kind of prefer the
original don't you the community has
discovered so much hidden content in
these games over the past year or so and
it's all thanks to this small but really
dedicated community of hackers and data
diggers who will all be listed in the
description so let's start with
something that for me made me want to
make this video in the first place
it's the recovery of every single
epitaph description hidden within the
network test files of Dark Souls 3 so in
case you've forgotten epitaphs were
those little gravestones that you could
read in the network test and back then
there was only four of them but it turns
out 43 of them were actually in the
game's files at the time and now every
single unused epitaph has been extracted
and then translated and then re added to
the game for our enjoyment that said
though most of these only add context to
characters and not much more the context
is important it gives flavor to the
environment and the characters one of my
favorites is this epitaph which talks
about the dedication of the abyss
Watchers it reads
grave of a brave army the man who fights
the abyss will die with a dull blade
there's also this really sad one which
is about the half-dragon creatures in
era filled dungeon whose misery was
actually entertainment for the law
no wonder it reads it was neither a
human nor a dragon in sadness he danced
to the royal family here he sleeps
there's even a line about the dedication
of the lothric Knights which reads fear
the knight loyalty beyond death to the
undying King which is cool because it's
an example of a hollow Knight still
being dedicated to the King even though
their hallowed and finally we have this
odd epitaph which says viewers who click
if the Bell next to the subscribe button
will be notified of new videos
such good law but perhaps the most
interesting ones are those talking about
the pilgrims these descriptions make a
ton of mentions of heaven and hell and
they emphasize how the pilgrims have
this longing to climb the high wall and
they're scattered all throughout the
game and they really drive home just how
difficult the pilgrims journeys have
been and considering the only pilgrims
to turn into angels are actually those
who make it to Worlds End maybe turning
into an angel is their reward for making
it to the end of the world for all of
those epitaphs and more you can check
out Lance's channel where he's dictated
all 43 of them but of all the things
changed in Dark Souls threes development
epitaphs might actually be the most
minor because here's something big what
you're seeing now is what remains of
Dark Souls threes scrapped bonfire
creation mechanic these animations were
extracted by Zhu Li the witch and
exposed by Senna discs a links in the
description and can you imagine what it
would have been like if it was possible
for you to drag corpses to a location of
your choosing and then create a bonfire
wherever you like it's rumored that this
is where you can see this character
doing in the opening cutscene at its
best this mechanic would have made the
world feel like a really grand adventure
because imagine if you were sort of
pushing through a really difficult level
you know you're risking death and you
want to get as far as you possibly can
before creating a next check
point right so you finally decide yep
this is as far as I can go so you create
a bonfire and you sort of make a camp in
that sense you rest up and then you push
forward into unknown territory I think
that's a really cool feeling but in
reality I feel like this system would
probably feel more like searching
through an entire parking lot wondering
where the hell you parked your bonfire
which level was it again was at a yellow
level oh no I think it was an orange
level more questions arise from this
though could bonfires be created
anywhere what if I want to put one
outside a boss's fog gate where do we
find bonfire creation tools and how many
bonfires could I create and honestly it
would have been a nightmare for them to
balance I think and I can see why it was
scrapped anyway once he decided where
you wanted your bonfire you could do
this back then this was likely called a
moonlight ceremony and it would have
changed the way that PvP works in Dark
Souls 3
thanks to leftover files in Dark Souls
threes Network test Lance managed to
hack back in the item that was required
to initiate a moonlight ceremony this
was called a ceremony sword of darkness
and it reads when used perform a
ceremony to envelop the world in
darkness I think we sort of saw the
echoes of these ceremonial swords in an
rescore and as a part of unrest line but
this ceremonial sword instead envelops
your world in darkness and the world
becomes moonlit with thick fog rolling
all around you the lighting work here is
gorgeous you can really see the
moonlight reflecting off the pavement
and slowly but surely we are piecing
together the earliest versions of this
game but what was the point of this
light state well thanks to the presence
of another item in the game's code we
can actually puzzle that out this one is
called the ceremony sword of flame when
used invade a world that has been
enveloped in darkness select this item
to perform an invasion ceremony so
therefore instead of invasion being
linked to your character's Mbits state
it was actually once linked to your
world state instead making your world
the arena to invade not your character
but there was one more ceremony sword
and it was called ceremony sword Battle
Royale
Eclipse and before you freak out don't
worry they probably never intended to
turn dark souls into fortnight even
though I actually think about all royal
mode would work pretty well the Dark
Souls know in the past Battle Royale was
simply a term that from software used to
describe their arena PvP modes and
perhaps this item would have invaded a
bunch of friendly phantoms and enemy
phantoms to sort of dish it out in your
world but in the end the only world
state we got was the Eclipse State we
could have had so many more some of
which are absolutely breathtaking this
one is called evening or dusk and it
paints the world in these really nice
sort of Twilight hues this one is called
moonlit night and it casts some serious
shadows on the environment with a moon
sort of silhouetting your surroundings
in a wonderfully cinematic way
here in IRRI Phil we seen noon which
isn't too different to that of the final
game but of course the world wasn't
always devoid of light in these states
because one of the most striking world
states was this one with an enormous
burning Sun overhead I kind of
understand sellers obsession all of a
sudden then we have the Eclipse State
which was a sort of blue variant with a
ring of light around it and finally we
have an incredibly surreal scene that I
never thought I would see in-game so
these dragon creatures were featured in
one of the earliest leaked screenshots
of Dark Souls 3 and while this scene
clearly inspired the scene that we got
in the full game with the pilgrim
butterflies these worm dragon like
creatures are pretty different
they even cast shadows upon the ground
which gives you a real sense that
they're actually up there above you
imagine if Dark Souls had a scene like
this in game where the Dragons returns
to the world this is the sort of thing
that makes me hope that they'll get to
Dark Souls for one day because it's
clear that they have so many unused
ideas just waiting in the wings many of
these ideas actually had to do with the
concept of the past and time travel
there actually is a time of day filter
called the past in Dark Souls 3 which
gives a sort of grayscale look to the
environment and it's very very similar
to what you would have experienced in
Dark Souls twos memory trips Lentz who
discovered all this points out that
every area that's currently accessible
does have a past filter applied to it
and imagine how good it would be for the
story of the game if we could sort of
see what the world was like in the past
and see what changed in the future
speaking of the past the Dark Souls twos
original story actually used to be based
around the
except of time travel and no souls born
game has more cut content than Dark
Souls 2 so this was stated in the design
works but duck souls 2 actually had a
really really troubled development about
halfway through from software thought
that it was best to overhaul the entire
game which left behind a lot of old
assets that originally had very
different purposes
luckily echoes of the old game still
remain in the files and thanks to the
work of Senators K and Loki to translate
we get a rare glimpse into what the
previous plot of Dark Souls 2 was going
to be put simply time travel was at the
core of the story and what you're seeing
on screen now is a recreation of a very
important scholar character named vel
Derek who was obsessed with a powerful
artifact called the pendulum of time
those amongst you with great memories
will remember that this blue frozen
globe was actually involved in some of
the earliest marketing materials for the
game but nothing about its design
actually ended up making it through to
the final game that is except for the
dialogue of the scholar which was hidden
deep within the game's files well Derek
says that to activate the pendulum we
would have had to find two things first
we have to find the dragon's jewel which
was a rare gem that dwells within the
womb of an ancient dragon which is
probably related to the ancient dragon
we fight in the dragon shrine and second
to get the pendulum to work we needed to
find the drop of time and this one's
really interesting so the drop of time
was rumored to have been discovered by a
miner who dug deep below a village that
ended up being destroyed by demons and
apparently when he dug below the water
there opened up a hole in space and time
teleporting the miner to a different
location far above ground does that
remind you of anything
honestly this sounds borderline
identical to the ruined city cutscene
that's seen in the opening especially
since there's water there's a giant hole
in the ground it teleports us to a place
above ground in a different time and you
even see the city untouched by time in
the reflection of the water so once you
put the pendulum of time together with
the drop of time and the dragon gem this
presumably would have led us to another
character who is discovered within Dark
Souls 2 his files the child version of
the Emerald Herald this might be the
cutest character to ever grace the souls
series the Emerald Herald in case you've
forgotten was half-dragon and she was
half-human and she gives you the aged
feather which apparently was an item
from her childhood that she looked at
and with it she conjured up a world of
endless possibilities the way that she
gives our character this item in the
opening cutscene is honestly kind of
heart-wrenching almost as if she's
imploring us to sort of remember her as
if they completely filled out her story
we actually would have gone back in time
and have known her when she was still a
child
you can check out Senators K's video on
the topic for more in recent years even
blood-borne has been dug into which is a
notoriously difficult task as there's no
PC version for the game nevertheless the
community always finds a way this is an
unseen animation from blood-borne it was
once used to crush a liver above your
character for before there was cold
blood there were fresh livers there were
large fresh livers there were very large
fresh livers and so on which could be
crushed to give you some blood echoes on
demand in our bodies the liver can
actually hold up to like 10% of the
body's blood at any given time so it
actually makes some sense for this item
to be a realistic source of blood echoes
although at the time the resource given
was still
called Souls and just like souls you
could actually get the fresh livers of
bosses as well which reveals the names
of the original bosses that were planned
to be in blood-borne some of the most
interesting ones up on the screen
blood-borne even had a character editor
at one point which was a way to reverse
any horrible abominations that you
regretted making at the start of the
game all you had to do was step up to
this mirror I bet most people haven't
even noticed in the hunters dream and
then just wear clothing to change
appearance this never made it into the
game and I'm not really sure why because
out of all the games being able to
change your appearance in a dream
actually make some sense but unlike the
mirror I can see why they removed these
these were called warped chairs and
there was something for your character
to sit in fall asleep in and then drift
off to the hunters dream in there was an
assortment of chair designs but no
matter what they look like there's a
problem with these because in some
environments they barely even look out
of place so imagine being about to die
in blood-borne you're out of blood vials
you're desperately going up to random
chairs and just hoping that it's a
checkpoint yeah I can see why they
removed it it's also possible that they
simply moved this concept over to Mikkel
ash and his students who all drift off
to their nightmare in a really similar
fashion and number 10 finally is a
personal favorite of mine and it's
something that I actually wish I could
have come up with an excuse to talk
about at the time because put simply a
dedicated group of chalice dungeon
prospectors recently discovered a whole
new labyrinth that had never been
explored before and it had some
fascinating bosses inside there's a full
explanation in the description but put
simply this small team of dungeon
prospectors managed to identify a glitch
that causes only 32 out of 200 possible
chalice dungeons to appear in its
chalices which means that we've been
locked out of
ton of dungeons until now so to get
around this they painstakingly rolled
back their saves every single time that
they wanted to explore a little bit
further and they kept doing this and
mapping out the dungeons until they
stumbled upon something really special
they found wandering bosses so these
bosses actually appear simply without
fog gates or a giant health bar just
wandering through the dungeon and
according to their reddit post five have
been found so far there's the abhorrent
beast there's the blood starved beast
there's the two Marian descendant
there's the two Marian elder and there's
the watchdog of the old Lords and
they're just wandering around like other
agreeable enemies for me personally
chalice dungeons have always been one of
the most tedious things in souls born
series so I respect the hell out of
anyone who's capable of having the
patience to explore hundreds of these
dungeons and map them out that's crazy
and the fact that they managed to
discover something in a three-year-old
game without the use of digging into the
data of the game is really really
impressive
so in conclusion all of these people
have kept content for these games going
long after many of us have dropped them
so we should show them some support and
check out their channels and the users
below in the description because there
is some seriously good stuff down there
thank you all for watching and I'll see
you next time and the next video is a
prepare to cry I promise
you